good afternoon and welcome to everyone
to the planning so the policy and
Regulatory committee
and while it's a fairly light agenda
today there might be some discussion on
some of the items
since we met last there's been two
significant events that have happened in
the district and I just wanted to make
quick reference to them in terms of the
emergency that we had during the
flooding and for any people that are out
there still that are having issues with
their house and other inconveniences our
thoughts are with you
and Then followed in the last few days
by some extremely high winds that have
caused damage throughout the whole
District so again thoughts go out to
those people it's certainly the
strongest wins I've seen in a number of
years in the time that I've been in Gore
so welcome to the meeting do we have any
apologies
and
be just one for Council McKinsey right
any other apologies
just quickly through the last
not everyone else is here so can I have
a mover for the apology please
councilor Dixon second
counselor Stringer all those in favor
say aye against carried are there any
conflicts of interest in terms of items
in the agenda today
or any other reason why councilors wish
to stand down from any other or from any
item
I could have a conflict on item
three
it it's of a general nature and it's
more for information so I think you'll
find there thank you
item one is the workplace harassment
prevention policy which is on pages 1 to
12 of the agenda and there's a report
from the general manager people and
culture that sets out the policy there
is there anything
to use in prison
just message the general manager of
people and culture to see if she can
come down to speak to it right did you
want to move to the next door yes we'll
move to the next item and come back the
next item on page 13 is the planning
update
um and it's great to actually see the
this update as part of the agenda rather
than the bulletins that we've received
and and it'd be good if the other
matters that are dealt with and the
bulletins can come into the agenda as
well
there's some good information there are
there any questions or feedback that
councilors want to give in terms of the
planning update
you'll I've got a couple of comments and
things just to address
um you'll see that there's a consent
there for Kai wearer Downs wind farm
for people's information the number of
towers has been reduced from 83 to 66
and it's compensated by increasing the
height of the towers from 145 to 165
meters and they're consent has been
processed
a question I guess for uh Katrina Ellis
in relation to the consent for 117 Main
Street matawara removal of part of a
designation will that trigger a need to
actually do some sort of change to
what's in the proposed District plan
I need to check that
um I understand that that requiring
Authority was aware of the district plan
and wanted to amend their designation
sooner rather than later so they had
sought to go through this process and
Steed but I'll check the proposed
District plan just to make sure that
they align
and thank you and I see that there is a
biodiversity working group being set up
that incorporate staff
as well as
representatives from environment South
and tongue at the funeral and key Stakes
holders such as forest and bird
Department of Conservation and Federated
farmers
what role if any do you envisage the
elected representatives having on the
working party
recognizing that any of the members of
the district plan hearing panel can take
no part in that yep but there may be
benefit in actually having one of the
rural counselors as part of it to give
some perspective at this point in time
the Committees at the officer level and
with the other parties it's also just
staff including the other councils but
in the first meeting they're going to
talk about the terms of reference and
whether that should be broadened out so
I visited it will be talked about at the
first working group meeting right and I
can bring any thoughts of this committee
there as well if you wish
we still haven't placed the district
planned subcommittee so if it's looking
at doing any changes to the plan I would
anticipate that reports will go to that
committee before goes through the formal
process definitely that's our
understanding of how the process will
right thank you it's helpful for myself
and and for um
other counselors
um also drawing a tension specifically
to part of the work that's being done at
this time on the outside of the district
plan is looking at financial assistance
where there's protected areas in the
district plan and also developing a
policy for development contributions so
are there any other comments or feedback
that councilors with wish to give
appears not so can I have a mover and a
second a pleas to the recommendation
which I believe is to the effect that
the report being received
so counselor uh
read and seconded by councilor McDonald
moving on to item three then which is
the resource management reform update
and there was a report that I've
prepared and it's just giving an update
for counselors in terms of where the
um
reviews or the updates are at at present
and noting in the middle there with a
series of bullet points of some measures
that come into immediate effect or are
in effect now
um
what happens from this point on is going
to be dictated a lot by what is in the
or what the outcome of the elections are
um
I'm from a technical point of view
curious as to how Provisions that
already enforced can be taken out again
without causing too much disruption so I
think it's not if there is a change of
government and a desire to repeal the
reform legislation it's not going to be
a simple quick process it'll be
complicated and in the meantime we must
continue to operate under the provisions
that we've got
I've also highlighted that there's a
draft of the national planning framework
out which is 545 pages long added to the
Thousand pages that are the legislation
so if any comments or feedback that
counselors want to give
okay
true Mr cheers have you read that is
that some light reading for you
as you would know I have cast my eyes
over the entire document so that I fully
understand what it is they're trying to
achieve
and and thankful that
um some of the matters aren't yet
included but it's virtually a draft
document of what a plan should look like
with a bit of choice in some places
any other comments feedback yes prone
to clarify exactly what a biodiversity
credit system is and how that works
please
the government of present is doing some
preliminary investigations as to the
practicality of having a scheme whereby
if you set aside areas for
protected natural areas biodiversity
areas reinstate forests and do things
like that you deserve to get a credit of
some sort
and whether they're creditors and
economic terms or something else that's
tradable is what they're exploring
Richard
just three years here I'm quite happy to
recommend the report but confirming that
uh what we just discussed then that's
not retrospective is it
I would extremely doubt it
was a shame for the uh hard-working
people that are involved in primary
industry that have made all these
inroads over the
many years of sitting aside of this
ground so but uh look I'm I'm fencing
off waterways yeah and also a number of
Rural residential people on the plant
about several thousand trees on their
property in the last few years I know
him well so
but I'm happy to move that uh reports
we've received I think it's probably
appropriate that we do take it with a
bit of credence that we are in a month
that's going to possibly change a number
of matters that we've had discussed at
Council so if you move that report to be
received I have a second to please
uh councilor Fraser all those in favor
say aye
against
carried
item four the marihiku Southland
Regional climate change working group
update and there was a document attached
to this that had a proposal
um general manager critical Services is
there anything you want to add on this
other than to highlight that there's an
expectation that we will adopt what is
in the principles and aspirations
through the chair thank you you know
they only take the reporters read the
only thing I'll add is that this is part
of the uh desire to implement or to
develop a regional strategy and so
there's principles and aspirations a key
part of that the group's working towards
developing that strategy so that it can
sit alongside the uh the ltps for the
Southland Council so and it's only think
of it any questions or feedbacks from
councilors please
appears to be none
so there are three recommendations at
the bottom of page 21
of the agenda
that the report we received the council
endorse the principles and aspirations
and that the council note the funding
for climate change adaptation program of
work will be included as part of the
long-term plan process and it needs to
help measure current greenhouse gas
emissions and that workers to be done
prior to June 2026.
can I have a mover for those three
motions please thank you councilor Dixon
a second uh
Council of read all those in favor say
aye
against carried
the next item is on pay
25 26.
item five the gore District Council
recycling update again another report
from the general manager critical
services and and I'm grateful for these
reports given their work that you've
been under for the last couple of weeks
thank you so is there anything that you
wish to add Jason
uh thank you Mr chair
um again this really is just an
information report so it follows on the
back of
um
legislation and information that came
out of central government in March
around moving towards a standardized
curbside recycling collection
um
it's I guess worth noting that through
this process Gore because it doesn't
currently have a full
recycling collection curbside collection
is given an extension to that time frame
um certainly on council's radar to
uh move towards rectifying that sooner
than the 2027 time frame and
I guess just for a bit of clarity for
people out there when we're talking
about standardized materials
particularly around the Plastics it can
be a little bit confusing there will be
um some uh Communications come out from
the government to support this ahead of
the February implementation date but
generally when we're talking about
Plastics one two and five we're talking
about things like uh drinking bottles
cleaned meat trays clear plastic
containers milk bottles
shampoo containers
margarine and ice cream bottles those
sorts of things they fit into this one
two and five in terms of the Plastics
and so there'll be a significant uh
campaign that is rolled out
um prior to that February date to help
provide some clarity around what's
what's in in terms of standardized
Recycling and what no longer fits that
or meets that criteria thank you any
comments questions from
counselors
councilor Dixon
thank you Mr chair um I just note that
countdown are actually collecting
plastic one two and five now so um
that's quite useful really information
for people
so you can just take it along and put it
in a bin somewhere can you
thank you
Joe
through you Mr chair what does this mean
for a local recycling organizations if
everything goes into the one bin for
sorting elsewhere today still get a
a hand on it of sorting out the aluminum
and cardboard Etc
Jason can you help
so I get through the chair
um it doesn't really change anything
from a
a collection of perspective perspective
Force organizations I guess such as
pakiki lions are still able to collect
um recycling in the same way that they
do it's just that curbside collections
will be
um standardized so that there's
consistency across the country this
means that when you're moving between
otago Southland waikato we're all
putting the same stuff in those bins and
so we're not having the same level of
contamination and recycling which is a
considerable problem across the country
and so that's really the purpose for
um there's also some discretion as
you'll see in The Gazette notice for
local authorities that they can still
decide which
um
some materials which can be accepted
through that first processes so still an
element of flexibility this really is
around curbside collection and so other
collections can still be fit for purpose
in terms of making sure we support our
communities and try and divert as much
waste from landfill as we can
thank you
any other feedback comments
thank you Mr chair I think currently two
parkikia are also recycling milk bottles
and some Plastics so and maybe we could
help them out with some communication
for the community
I'm sure it's been noted
right any other comments
or I can have a mover a second of that
the report be received please
so uh councilman McDonald
seconder
councilor Stringer thank you all those
in favor say aye
against carried
will now return to item one and I
understand the chief executive is able
to respond to any questions that we may
have in terms of the workplace
harassment prevention policy
so is there any
um feedback or comments that counselors
wish to make
I'll start if I could then in terms of
to the chief executive have the staff
had an opportunity to comment on this
and should they
it's a very question and both ways Mr
chairman
um I'm just trying to think where the
staff have had the opportunity to
comment on this this is a council policy
mind you so it is The Preserve of the
council I
want to ask some of my fellow senior
leadership team members where they can
recall or thy shaking their heads I
can't recall so the answer is no
um can we Circle that absolutely and a
good point
if if it's a wish of the council we can
still create the staff because most of
our Council policies and for example
we've just as a staff recently developed
a drug and alcohol
policy and that was circulated to staff
for common before it was implemented
that's a management policy this is a
council one I'm more than happy to
circulate it I think it will be very
good for staff to have and put into it
um one of the things I was going to
emphasize that I think is as welcome as
the definitions of and a contemporary
sense of what is bullying and what is
not bullying because I think too often
now the cards played uh and if it's
Performance Management related it's not
bullying it's just some it's just a
function of ensuring that an employee is
operating at the expected level so more
than happy Mr chair to circulate to
staff and to bring back any feedback
from staff to this committee before the
policy is finally ratified we do have a
current policy in vote but it's it's
quite dated and with the evolution of
thinking around some of these issues
it's time that we updated it and we've
since of course as alluded to you by
Nikki Cooper who unfortunately can't be
with us was visited by Copeland Ashcroft
law just to make sure that we've got
everything in line with modern
legal and organizational cultural
expectations
what's the view of councilors would you
like to see staff given the opportunity
of commenting on it before it's adopted
I see a number of nodding Heats
um
they've been the case but we'll um I
mean the motion in the moment but it
probably means that if people have got
any minor changes to wording that they
might think appropriate and I've got
several we can talk about that
informally prior to that being
circulated
so what that points to is then that the
recommendation that we have be received
and adopted
I'd like to amend that and move it that
the workplace harassment prevention
policy be circulated to staff with an
opportunity to comment prior to being
reported back to this committee
can I have a second being
sorry I think you Mr chair just
procedurally under we want to change the
recommendations together with counselors
and also staffs we get feedback at the
same time meaning it comes back with the
edits so it can just be passed sure I'm
happy to have it worded that way
Susan
you pick that up being so circulated to
councilors and staff
so can I have a second before that form
please ending question
can you put a time frame around that
um as part of the circulation then the
staff can come up with a time frame
rather than I would hope that it's for
our next meeting
Executives chair it will be time so the
next meeting you'll get the feedback
from both staff and counselors and with
some recommendations from staff of what
what a finalized policy should look like
so with that Andy happy to Second it
thank you
let's move by myself seconded by
councilor Fraser all those in favor say
aye
against carried
that brings us to the end of the agenda
and the I will close the meeting thank
you councilors and for the staff and
members of the pub